>> WHEN IT COMES TO THE GAS
PRICES, WE ARE GOING THROUGH AN
INCREDIBLE TRANSITION THAT IS
TAKING PLACE THAT GOD WILLING
WHEN IT'S OVER WE WILL BE
STRONGER IN THE WORLD WILL BE
STRONGER AND LESS RELIANT ON
FOSSIL FUELS WHEN THIS IS OVER.
>> Shannon: PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
INCREDIBLE TRANSITION COMMENT ON
SURGING GAS PRICES MAY NOT BE
SITTING WELL WITH THE NEARLY
40 MILLION AMERICANS TRAVELING
FOR THE MEMORIAL DAY WEEKEND.
THE NATIONAL AVERAGE PRICE OF
GAS AT $4.59 PER GALLON.
A NEW POLL FINDS 95% OF
AMERICANS SAY INFLATION IS A
CONCERN.
THE ENERGY SECRETARY TELLING
AMERICANS THE PRESIDENT IS ON
TOP OF IT.
>> HE IS OBSESSED WITH THE FACT
THAT GAS PRICES ARE SO HIGH AND
PEOPLE ARE HURTING.
THIS IS A GLOBAL ISSUE.
WHAT CAN HE DO?
SO YOU CAN EXHORT THE OIL AND
GAS INDUSTRY TO INCREASE SUPPLY.
I WISH THEY WOULD DO IT FASTER
SO THAT YOU CAN BRING THOSE
PRICES DOWN.
AND IT TELLS US THAT THAT'S WHY
YOU HAVE TO AT THE SAME TIME
ACCELERATE OUR MOVEMENT TO CLEAN
ENERGY.
YOU CAN WALK AND CHEW GUM.
YOU CAN DO BOTH.
>> Shannon: LET'S START THERE.
GEORGE, YOU ARE A LITTLE FIRED
UP TODAY SO LET'S CHANNEL SOME
OF THAT ENERGY.
OIL AND GAS, PRODUCE MORE.
THEY ARE SAYING WOULD LIKE TO
BUT WE HAVE UNREGULATED CARE WE
CAN.
>> Judge Jeanine: SHE IS THE
SAME ONE WHO SAID BUT THAT I HAD
A MAGIC WAND.
REMEMBER THAT ONE?
HERE'S THE BOTTOM LINE.
THEY ARE CELEBRATING THE FACT
THAT GAS IS SO HIGH.
THEY THINK EVERYBODY'S GOING TO
BUY AN ELECTRIC CAR.
THEY DON'T REALIZE THAT WE CAN'T
AFFORD ELECTRIC CARS.
SENIOR CITIZENS WILL NEVER BE
ABLE TO AFFORD AN ELECTRIC CAR.
THEY ARE CRUSHING THE MIDDLE
CLASS.
AS FAR AS THEY'RE CONCERNED,
IT'S NOTHING FOR THEM TO WORRY
ABOUT BECAUSE THEY'VE GOT THE
DEALS.
CHINA IS GOING TO MAKE
BATTERIES.
THEY HAVE WITH HIM FROM
AFGHANISTAN AND WE'RE GOING TO
GET CRUSHED.
>> Shannon: I DON'T KNOW WHERE
THEY THINK ELECTRICITY COMES
FROM.
YOU'VE GOT TO THINK ABOUT THAT.
GREG, IN 2008 BEFORE
PRESIDENT OBAMA BECAME
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
>> Greg: IN MY EARLY 20s.
>> Shannon: EXACTLY.
IT MIGHT BE A HAZE.
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER IT.
MIGHTY BE FUZZY.
HE SAID AS A CANDIDATE YOU CAN
BUILD A COAL-FIRED POWER PLANT
YOU WANT TO BUT MY POLICIES WILL
MAKE IT GO BANKRUPT.
>> Greg: THIS IS "LET THEM EAT
CAKE" REPOSITIONED AS AN
ALTRUISTIC SACRIFICE.
YOU'RE GOING TO LOSE YOUR
SAVINGS AND YOU'RE NOT GOING TO
BE ABLE TO GO ON VACATION.
BUT IN THIS GREAT TRANSITION,
THINK OF YOUR CONTRIBUTION TO
THIS GREAT LEAP FORWARD.
NONE OF THEM PARTICIPATE IN THE
SACRIFICE BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE TO.
I LOVE HOW JOE MINIMIZES OUR GAS
PAIN.
WHAT IF WE DID THAT TO HIM?
AT HIS AGE, HE HAS A LOT OF GAS
PAIN.
>> Judge Jeanine: I WAS
WAITING FOR THAT.
>> Greg: HOW STUPID YOU HAVE
TO BE TO BELIEVE YOU CAN CUT A
POPULATION FROM A PRIMARY ENERGY
SOURCE WITHOUT HAVING A VIABLE
CONSISTENT ENERGY SOURCE.
YOU CAN'T SAY THAT ABOUT SOLAR.
YOU CAN'T SAY THAT ABOUT
WINDMILLS BECAUSE THEY AREN'T
CONSISTENT.
I DON'T THINK ANY OF US ARE
AGAINST ALTERNATIVE ENERGY
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT'S NUCLEAR.
BUT THIS IS NUTS.
THEY REALIZE NUCLEAR IS THE ONLY
ALTERNATIVE ENERGY THAT'S GOING
TO WORK AND IT TOOK THEM 40
YEARS OF DEMEANING THIS
INDUSTRY.
TRYING TO CLOSE DOWN ALL THESE
FACILITIES.
I THINK NOW THEY ARE REOPENING
THE ONE IN CALIFORNIA.
GAVIN NEWSOM IS REOPENING ONE.
THAT IS A SEA CHANGE.
A BIG DEAL.
I CREDIT MICHAEL SHELLENBERGER
ON THAT.
HE'S BEEN PUSHING IT.
>> Shannon: SO GREG SAID LET
THEM EAT CAKE.
>> Greg: I SAID THEY SAID
THAT.
ARE YOU EVEN LISTENING TO ME?
>> Shannon: I HANG ON YOUR
EVERY SYLLABLE EVERY DAY.
I'M NOT SURE PEOPLE CAN AFFORD
CAKE.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
HERE'S A LOOK AT YOUR PICNIC OR
YOUR COOKOUT.
14.7%.
HOT DOGS UP 7%.
PI, IT DOESN'T SAY CAKE.
PIE.
BEER.
JOEY, IT'S GOING TO BE AN
EXTENSIVE COOKOUT.
>> Joey: IT IS.
IF I HAVE CAKE, I WILL EAT IT
TOO.
>> Shannon: WHAT'S THE POINT
OF HAVING CAKE?
>> Joey: NOT TO DERAIL THIS.
I FEEL LIKE AFTER THE LAST
SEGMENT WE MIGHT NEED SOME
DERAILING.
ONE THING I HATE ABOUT THIS,
IT'S NOT ABOUT HOW YOU GET TO
THE MOVIE THEATER OR EVEN HOW
YOU GET TO WORK.
FOR MILLIONS OF AMERICANS, THIS
IS HOW YOU WORK.
FOR PEOPLE TO DRIVE A TRUCK FOR
A LIVING.
PEOPLE THAT OWN A LAWN
MAINTENANCE.
GAS GOES INTO EVERYTHING ON THAT
TRAILER THAT YOU'RE GOING TO USE
ON YOUR LAWN AND MAKE 20 BUCKS
TODAY.
IT ISN'T JUST ABOUT CONVENIENCE.
IT'S ABOUT LIVELIHOOD.
WE SAY I WISH THEY WOULD PRODUCE
MORE.
YOU RAN ON A CAMPAIGN OF
BANKRUPTING OIL AND GAS, TAKING
INVESTMENT AWAY.
NOW YOU PRETEND THAT THAT'S NOT
A FACTOR.
I DON'T CARE HOW MANY LEASES
THEY HAVE.
A LEASE IS ONLY AS GOOD AS THE
OIL UNDERNEATH THE GROUND AND
WHEN THIS ADMINISTRATION TOOK
OFFICE, THERE WAS A RUN-ON LAND
LEASES BECAUSE FOR SMALL
COMPANIES, THAT'S THE ONLY
COLLATERAL YOU HAVE TO GET
INVESTMENT SO YOU GO OUT AND YOU
LEASE 1,000 LEASES.
IF TEN PRODUCE OIL, YOU'RE GOOD.
IT'S THE LEASES THAT ARE YOUR
COLLATERAL TO GET JOE
BILLIONAIRE TO INVEST IN YOU AND
GUESS WHAT JOE BILLIONAIRE IS
NOT GOING TO INVEST IN YOU IF
THERE IS NOT AN ATMOSPHERE OF
RETURN ON INVESTMENT SO THAT'S A
PROBLEM AND BEYOND ALL THAT YOU
GO BACK TO NUCLEAR, THE CLEANEST
ENERGY THAT EXIST.
3-MILE ISLAND WAS A LONG TIME
AGO.
THAT TECHNOLOGY IS NOT WHAT WE
DO ANYMORE.
WE HAVE MICRO-REACTORS.
RESIDENTIAL REACTORS.
WE HAVE PLANS FOR REACTORS TO
POWER A NEIGHBORHOOD.
AND YOU KNOW WHO FINALLY GOT THE
UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT TO OPEN
UP ITS MATERIAL FACILITIES FOR
PEOPLE WHO HAVE DESIGN NEEDS,
REPUBLICANS DID.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
I'M NOT BLAMING DEMOCRATS.
I AM SAYING I KNOW THE PERSON
THAT HELPED WRITE THAT
LEGISLATION.
THAT'S WHAT WE NEED TO SPEED UP
AND MAKE THINGS HAPPEN.
THE DEFENSE INDUSTRY LOBBIES
EVERY DAY FOR NUCLEAR
TECHNOLOGIES.
FOR SECURITY REASONS.
YOU'VE GOT TO HIT ALL THE
PLAYERS THAT MAKE THIS WORSE.
NUCLEAR IS THE WAY TO GO.
I FULLY SUPPORT NUCLEAR.
>> Shannon: YOU ARE NUCLEAR.
>> Joey: I AM HOPING TO
RADIATE MY LEGS BACK.
>> Shannon: WE ARE CHEERING
FOR YOU IN THAT RESPECT.
IN THE MEANTIME WHILE WE WAIT
FOR THESE THINGS TO COME TO
FRUITION, JPMORGAN IS AMONG
THOSE SAYING BRACE YOURSELVES.
FOR $6 A GALLON.
NATIONAL AVERAGE.
NOT JUST CALIFORNIA.
BY THE END OF SUMMER, BY AUGUST.
56% OF PEOPLE SAYING THEIR
FINANCIAL SITUATION IS GETTING
STEADILY WORSE AND THAT'S THE
HIGHEST NUMBER THAT POLL HAS
MEASURE.
C7 I DON'T DISAGREE WITH ANY OF
THE REMEDIES THAT HAVE BEEN
OUTLINED.
WHEN I WAS IN CONGRESS,
REPUBLICANS WERE AFRAID 3-MILE
ISLAND AS MUCH AS DEMOCRATS
WERE.
I THINK WE HAVE TO BUILD
NUCLEAR, BUILD BATTERIES, DRILL
AND FRACK.
WITH THE WAR HAS SHOWN US AS THE
VULNERABILITY AND HOW WE ARE
SQUEEZED BY A PERSON WHOSE
CULTURE WE THOUGHT WAS LARGELY
IRRELEVANT IN THE GLOBAL
ECONOMIC CONVERSATION.
IT FORCES US HOW TO RECEIVE
RETHINK HOW WE THINK ABOUT THE
MOMENT.
IN TERMS OF THE MOMENT, IT WAS
REPORTED LAST WEEK.
BEING IN CONVERSATION WITH
VENEZUELA.
PEOPLE WERE UPSET, HOW COULD YOU
DO THAT.
WHEN YOU'RE SERIOUS ABOUT TRYING
TO ALLEVIATE CONSUMERS AND LOWER
THOSE PRICES FROM $6 TO $5 TO $4
TO $2.50.
WE HAVE TO MAKE UNCOMFORTABLE
CHOICES.
THE IMMEDIATE FRAME.
MY ORIENTATION POLITICS IS NOT
TO BLAME.
WE CAN DO THAT.
I WANT TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE GET
GOING AT THE MOMENT AND HOW WE
PREPARE, HOW WE ENSURE THAT FIVE
YEARS FROM NOW OR TWO YEARS FROM
NOW WE DON'T FACE THIS
CHALLENGE.
WE ARE LITTERED WITH MISTAKES.
I MAKE MISTAKES.
MY COLLEAGUES MAKE MISTAKES BUT
WHAT WE DO GOING FORWARD?
NUCLEAR, DRILLING, BATTERIES,
FRACKING.
MAKING CLEANER PRODUCTS
INCLUDING PLASTIC.
BUT WE HAVE TO GET OUR PRICES
LOWER.
>> Shannon: HOPEFULLY FIVE
YEARS FROM NOW IT DOES NOT
INVOLVE GOING TO CRAZY DICTATORS
TO GET GAS FROM THEM.
>> Judge Jeanine: CAN I SAY
ONE THING.
>> Shannon: YOU CAN BUT THEY
ARE GOING TO SCREAM IN MY EAR.
>> Judge Jeanine: THAT'S OKAY.
YOU KNOW HOW BIG AN ELECTRIC
BATTERY IS WHEN YOU GET RID OF
AN ELECTRIC CAR.
IT IS AS BIG A